[Music]
in almost got away news submitted by
free sugar fish a Brazilian gang leader
trussed up as his daughter in an attempt
to escape from prison this [ __ ] was
creepy everybody was sending me this
[ __ ] they're like it looks like you oh
[Laughter]
but that's true it does yeah I don't
know everyone kept sending it to me cuz
your eyes are like it's the same shape
as a mask but because the the slits so
small your eyes just look all black oh
that with the mask that he has on so
this guy he's a Brazilian drug traffic
trafficker known as shorty and yes so he
this is what you look like you know he's
dead now right
I was gonna get that she said this is
what he looks like but I'm like damn
he's dead though okay oh so so you just
fall Game of Thrones you don't even know
how he died that's true but I still know
that he's gonna die sometime yeah but
then it's harder to make fun of them
when you know that they die it was gonna
save her for the N girl oh well now you
know I'm gonna make fun of them anyways
let's keep going
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so he was trying to dress
up as a 19 year old daughter and he
actually left his daughter in his cell
as he was trying to escape she's also
gonna be getting charged for like
helping him escape escape was leaving
her there and they're gonna be like
whoops you're not him
you're gonna go - you're free to go I
assume that they that's what they
thought like he was gonna get away and
then eventually they're gonna with that
look we're gonna let her out I thought
what they were gonna wear I thought he
was I didn't assume that he was a [ __ ]
I thought he was gonna get out and then
of course you're gonna go wait a second
why is there a girl in here so stare to
start retracing the steps but by that
time he's probably telling his daughter
like hey don't worry I know they're
gonna catch you and start trying to find
me but me and my boys were gonna break
you out somehow maybe with that look he
should have just gone
like this and then pretended he was a
sex doll cuz he [ __ ] looks like one
actually said that because of his
nervousness I think he's actually a mask
so this is a video of all day was his
daughter wearing this mask walking in
then he's like well that didn't work I
like the mass better
it was so expressionless I thought that
was his real face and he put makeup on
that's creepy and so there's a [ __ ]
donut Mickey Mouse thing yeah they're
saying that they also have arrested
eight other people one of them including
a pregnant woman who they think she was
the one who smuggled in the mask and
stuff
through her [ __ ] because she's pregnant
[Music]
but yeah so like Gio said was found dead
three days after his foiled plot
to his gate and so they said that he had
committed suicide with the bedsheets so
funny that he killed himself with a
bedsheet
that's what laughing ah hmm I missed it
what no no no [ __ ] I create well yeah
so girl L caught that how he died okay
suicide yeah
why would he do such a thing because
he's embarrassed yes oh it's that
embarrassing well not only that but were
they making fun of them so not only that
but in Brazil right now the prisons are
really really deadly there was this
recent crazy-ass riot were set 52 people
died 18 of them were beheaded walked off
Wow I heard about that
with what apparently they were they were
like heads were just rolling down them
Wow
so Brazil indeterminate hey don't bug
around
so that's they got Amazonian headhunter
tribes in there huh so this guy he was
serving a 73 year prison sentence for
his role in this gang and so he this is
the second time he he tried to escape
the first time he did successfully
escape with 31 other people oh wow what
do ya'll dress like the same room no so
they all went hey that went through the
sewer goddamn that's not a really secure
[ __ ] prison
31 people we just bounce and they have
riots like what is this prison bounced
out of here and women could smuggle
should do their [ __ ] yeah I'd want to
escape too if people are getting going
head listen and they're playing soccer
with it yep [ __ ] yeah did you hear about
that yeah they're playing soccer with
the heads Brazilians are really good at
soccer so yeah some sick [ __ ] you're
doing that [ __ ] with like like Dutch
yeah and it's all like on their knee and
then yeah it's like hacky sack like head
to head
is it oh my god my god so heavy doesn't
even bounce like that takes some real
skin hurt my head cuz they it's really
it hurts
[ __ ] yeah I miss ball yeah but dude
Brazilians they play a lot of soccer
their school yeah yeah yeah that's true
I did do a lot of capoeira and [ __ ] so I
mean yeah they get it like wondering
what happens to the daughter so she they
found her in his cell and so right now
she faces six months to two years in
prison for helping isn't she like
sixteen or eighteen nineteen nineteen
also they're gonna try her as an adult I
don't even know if that's so he was so
embarrassed he didn't want to be made
fun of anymore that he suicide see this
is what bullying is so wrong
bullying they're both there he's afraid
of being bullied so hard in jail that
he'd said I want to be bullied anymore
I'm gonna commit suicide that's what
happened I mean they're playing soccer
with heads too there's a little scarier
intent but the real issue here is
bullying you're right you're right so we
should stop bullying you right now
especially in Brazilian jails we need to
stop bullying just all you everything
you stop hey Brazilian just can we stop
bullying thank you I think that cover it
but I didn't why he went to prison again
cuz remember he escaped and I told you
guys he escaped so a month later he got
caught because he was involved in
another criminal act where he was
robbing uber drivers is robbing
something yeah so he not over drivers
but he ended up getting caught again and
sent to prison again because he couldn't
stop him
Brazil's wild man I love watching Brazil
videos where like people are getting
robbed at gunpoint you love yeah because
like I like it when I when I see them
getting caught okay got it
I don't like people getting robbed that
that sucks
but then when the robber the tables are
turned and then they become the prey I
love I like that [ __ ] I like seeing guys
trying to steal Amazon packages and they
get they get caught when it blows up on
their face
yep City of God I was always like I
don't ever want to go to Brazil I know
cuz like they grab a chicken and kill it
in front of you what no I think just
talking about the kids with ak-47 or
even in the rich areas or kidnapping
people girl that happens here I know
that was gonna lead to saying like it's
crazy that I'm so afraid like other
people like we're always so afraid of
other countries but even in this very
country other countries are having
trouble yeah
travel advisory warnings because of all
the shootings are happening in this
country so I'm like I want to go to
Brazil I would like to have resilience
be we should go for the barbecue and
then get the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's I don't blame people when they're
just all scared of coming to America or
Mexico or going to other places cuz I'm
[ __ ] scared too I go with you stop
bullying that's what it does it's all it
all starts at bullying yeah I'm not
scared of Brazilians and Mexicans I'm
scared of the be headers yeah and I
don't want them to come wild man oh yeah
that's just scary as hell yeah you have
that [ __ ] on my chest is like the [ __ ]
the Salvadorians are known for doing
that during gangs the Dorian's do you
have gangs like that in Canada I was all
gay go they were so cute
the Maple Street gang they're [ __ ]
tough the Maple Street gang yeah have
you heard of them
no they're tough you sound really nice
though they all have maple leaf tattoos
yeah I didn't they so like black market
maple syrup that's right it's like
watered-down beautiful maple syrup and
they have a black market moose Ryan's
company yep yeah make a lot of money
from them like wearing the reading all
this stuff I need to get on this trip
advisor do you have gangs and stuff we
do yeah are they scary I do they like
kill people and behead people and stuff
yeah that's scary
everywhere has these things why I just
never see them any can be like when I'm
in Canada everyone seems so friendly
it's like other parts and definitely
like outside of Vancouver that aren't
that safe but Canada's so relaxing I
feel like I could just fart anywhere and
I'll be okay ah
let me look at your home you know if you
have as far to anywhere you're gonna get
your ass kicked
yep - I'll just beat you up
yeah did you just fart Matt it's a co-op
yeah I'm actually being serious whatever
you do do not fart here I actually did
at a coffee shop and had my headphones
on and I was like I don't know how loud
that was lucky they didn't get your ass
beat
yeah and your own agent coffee shop
opposite Phil's coffee you know just
like i sat there and I was like oh [ __ ]
and I'm like how did he creep on or
castle they're accepting to you it's all
those things where you thought it would
be quiet but it was like wow could have
been the music I felt it yeah ambient
music that's true we'll see rattles it's
pretty much I should just pretend like
nothing happened I'm like well hopefully
no one heard it because my music was
kind of loud but I like I know it was
kind of or maybe they're playing poker
and he farted to one of the beats really
he's got blended in a little bit okay
maybe it was a longer drum beat during
that and while you really ripped one
that's true maybe yeah just kind of like
time it to just so when something's loud
do that battle one time when you wake up
oh yeah
[Music]